c'est donc l'aboutissement de 16 ans
d'enquêté deux révélations depuis cet
après midi maurice papon est devant ses
juges à bordeaux ses avocats ont
aussitôt demandé sa libération philippe
denis pierre dick
maurice papon arrive au palais de
justice à bord d'une voiture de tourisme
cette image sera la seule autorisée par
l'accusé eelv a refusé d'être
photographiés dans son box
entre deux policiers poursuivis pour
crimes contre l'humanité
il veut à tout prix éviter d'avoir
l'apparence d'un coupable avec la même
volonté
l'un de ses avocats à d'emblée demandé
sa mise en liberté aux magistrats de la
cour
maurice papon a passé sa première nuit
dans une cellule de 10 mètres carrés
selon m e varaut lui imposer cette
situation pendant 11 semaines serait
dangereux pour sa santé
il a été réveillé trois fois par la
lumière il a dormi trois heures à cause
des bruits
il a été réveillé le matin alors qu'il
doit avoir une siège de l'ong à repos en
raison de l'état cardiaque
on lui a plu et du thé alors que le cap
et le bep est interdite
il est incontestable mais si ce régime
continue quelques jours la question sera
résolue comble qu'elle se taise en
réalité le moral mais selon le procureur
général desclaud la loi exige qu'un
accusé soit détenu jusqu'au verdict pas
question de faire une exception pour
maurice papon
ce magistrat a reçu le soutien des
parties civiles
est-ce que les gens là il est à la place
où il aurait dû être il ya 50 ans ou
même condamné à la réclusion criminelle
à perpétuité pour crimes contre
l'humanité
maurice patron n'irez pas en prison s'il
était aujourd'hui remis en liberté tant
que la cour de cassation n'est pas cette
nuit la cour a finalement décidé de
faire examiné l'accusé par des experts
médicaux qui rendront demain leurs
conclusions avant même que les jurés
n'étaient été tirés au sort
le procès papon a commencé par une passe
d'armes ce jury qui sera composé de cinq
hommes et de quatre femmes dont les deux
tiers ont moins de 35 ans